il ya plusieurs facteurs pour expliquer
cette situation positive
déjà on peut dire que la finlande avoir
mon bien géré la crise et que les
niveaux d'infections sont cinq fois
inférieur à la moyenne de l'union
européenne
une des raisons principales c'est que la
finlande a réagi très tôt dès le 16 mars
l'état a déclaré l'état d'urgence et a
instauré un seul confident donc comme
vous disiez on pouvait encore sortir
dans les pas les limitations de 1
kilomètre d'une heure par jour donc on
avait le droit de se déplacer
relativement facilement les écoles vers
sites et musées bibliothèques restaurant
tout a été fermé et aussi ils ont fait
pas mal de restriction niveau les
frontières 40 elle recommandé quand on
voyage et l on s'y confiner la région de
aussi manqué la région du sud du pays où
se trouvent elles si qui donc on ne
pouvait pas sortir ni rentrer dans la
région de boules six mois et comme vous
le disais la finlande a pas vraiment
connu un véritable confinement vous
pouvez vraiment sortie ratée librement
n'y avait pas de demande de prêt vue etc
explique aussi c'est que les hôpitaux
n'ont pas été engorgés a l'air en ce
moment le nombre de personnes en soins
intensifs et autour de 13 donc sans
commune mesure avec d'autres pays en
europe et dvd le dès le début de
l'épidémie
les hôpitaux ont vraiment su vraiment
attendu à un scénario catastrophe qui
finalement n'est pas vraiment arrivé
donc on s'inquiétait plusieurs étaient
petites structures que dans les grands
hôpitaux mais ils ont su gérer vraiment
la situation est aussi la finlande a
fait des tests de des campagnes de tests
assez rapidement qu'ils ont plutôt bien
marché donc la finlande a vraiment su
prendre des mesures très rapidement des
mesures qui ont été lui qui paraissent
beaucoup plus légère que dans l'ouest de
l'europe mais qui ont été très bien très
bien suivi ce qui explique en partie à
et très bons résultats la finlande
[Musique]